good morning Jim good morning how are
you it was close but we edged out the
Big Bang Theory is the most popular TV
show in a mirror yeah you know it's hard
to compete against live events though
dan isn't it I mean you know we're here
creating all week and y'all just throw
it on and see what
how would it do how would you do if you
did a live version of Big Bang Theory
I mean I'd probably soil myself um no I
don't know you know I've done plenty of
live theater I'm intrigued by the idea I
I don't know I think it sounds like yeah
you know what it could be really fun it
could be really fun there's no way we
get through without some sort of mishap
though but I guess that's the joy of it
yes yeah that would be great I mean
there's nothing better than doing it
live as you as you found out when you
were playing God on Broadway that feel
is something that you can't capture in
anything else that you do no it's true
it's true except that you know I have
there's so many people that would be the
quote-unquote audience that aren't in
the room with you if it was just going
over camera like I don't know that
sounds that sounds not I you know what I
want to talk more about spin
do you take spin classes well it's very
funny I'm a recent convert to the spin
Todd started taking spin and I went once
with him and I was like Oh God and then
I thought I'd kind of like to go back
and I went back and now I really really
liked it but I do I do the flywheel I
went once to the soul cycle and I need
to go back because it's a very different
vibe I'm a well I was gonna say I'm
surprised I'm not surprised that you
like soul cycle you're a little mystical
like that I guess mystical I don't know
you like your candles and your frou-frou
and your whatever that is true and I
love interior decorating as well yes
it's it's all of those things but I did
you like flywheel I didn't want to
compete enough with myself that I didn't
need to compete when I was doing
something like that and that's what it's
all about there's numbers there you know
I know I
no I know but see the thing is also but
like I don't put myself on the board
like I don't like so I bet it helps me
gauge what I'm doing and I the thing I
need to go back to SoulCycle for is I
have a hard time understanding what I
should be aiming for like I would the
one time I went like I was basically
done halfway through the class I think
it's because I put torque up too high
and so I kind of blew my legs out and I
was like well this isn't that women
pacing yourself at all do famous people
go to your spin class it's like mom I
have seen a couple of other people like
from a couple of TV shows and stuff but
no actually there's a fair amount of I
guess you'd call them normal people
maybe they're executives or whatever
there's a lovely woman who on the
wine-shop who goes a lot well there
Monroe if you sit in the front row you
got a back row oh I am I am too but if
are you really oh yeah you can't go
front row those are the people who think
they could instruct the class and they
probably could and I cannot so yeah I
don't need you looking at me while I
spend and I also saw a workout video
where you were you're it's a JJ Watt
video yes led well it what's funny
though is that I don't really do much
very good in the gym but for some reason
I have this workman like aspect of me I
suppose that can push heavy weight and
that's not that heavy for everybody but
but for me that's that's very heavy can
you out bench McLovin
no oh I don't know probably I think
McLovin bench is a decent amount of
weight from what I understand right 204
times best I don't really know what I do
I don't know what I do I know that like
if I'm holding if I'm this is so stupid
but if I'm doing like a like a dumbbell
press I think like a solid wrap of eight
with like fifty is about as high as I've
ever gone that's me huh that's good
is that it I mean what would that
translate to in a straight bar dumbbell
press though right
McLovin hundred according my math I
would like to know I understand that but
do you understand that doing the bar
full bar is a different thing that this
is the dumbest conversation I've ever
had no it's not
we know Dumber ones I miss Jim he's Jim
Parsons a Big Bang Theory he's also in
hidden figures by the way which is out
now Kevin Costner is on talking about
that great top rated Kevin is that first
time you were around Kevin Costner yeah
I worked with him and um I really really
liked him he was like he still is one of
the nicest people
he's so and just kind of goes without
saying I guess that it still struck me
he's so he's so in love with the craft
of making movie and he's a real he's a
joy to be around on a set because he's
just I mean he's done all parts of it
the writing the directing the acting and
and he's just very hands-on but not in
an irritating way it's just it's really
neat but do you you play a genius in the
movie yeah but in the Big Bang Theory
you're are you more of a savant no I
mean what are you maybe a little bit I
mean he's a genius they both have
problems relating to other people
apparently I don't know yeah no they're
both geniuses I mean okay I guess
Sheldon do savant what are you laughing
at
I do you want to play a dumb guy yeah I
like playing dumb people I used to play
dumb people more often but do I make you
play a dumb guy when you come on their
show like do I dumb you down no okay I
just don't think so
okay what'd you just say that's a
stupidest conversation you've ever had
and like oh I pull myself out of it and
I rise above the fray I didn't know Todd
was having a procedure trip he's always
having procedure yeah I know he is but
like we've been communicating about
coming on I didn't realize that he was
not that he was ailing Duke Jim whatever
you do don't ask fritzy about the
procedure okay I won't because you get
pictures you're going to go
long diatribe on you know no one needs
to see that it's gonna be a PowerPoint
is what's gonna be so here's something
funny I keep saying pride goeth before
the fall so I posted that video where
I'm pushing that sled and I'm and I'm
damn proud of it
and last night I stubbed my toe so hard
on a gate that keeps the dogs in like
corralled into the kitchen area yes that
I'm now on the look I'm on I'm gonna
have to go to doctors day I think I
broke my foot is that going to affect
BIGBANG's effect no one has that big
bang
Sheldon doesn't have to dance usually
but uh but I don't think I'll be
sledding for a while I'm afraid maybe
I'm wrong I think it's x-ray but it
doesn't look good and it doesn't feel
good what roles have you passed on movie
was oh oh I don't know I mean I really
don't know I mean it's hard to say I you
know something like hidden figures comes
down and I knew the director already and
and so it was an offer as opposed to
like an audition and so I I loved him
and I wanted to work with him again so I
probably would have said yes no matter
what are you going after roles or do the
roles come after you it depends it
depends it's it's it's about 5050 I mean
the the tricky thing has been because of
the TV schedule there's a lot of
scheduling issues so that's kind of
caught like I don't have a full year in
front of me every time to go to start
booking things or whatever but the other
thing is it's just it's not I think
you'll hear this from a lot of people
it's it's it's not it never gets a whole
lot easier to try and find work it's
very it's kind of funny like that but
nothing I mean I get a little easier but
it's like there's always still a fight
and and you have to really work for it
and there's a thousand other weird
little hurdles that's what I'm finding
anyway maybe I'm just not well-liked
maybe that's the problem
yeah I'm sure that's it okay are you
going now but are you going to Houston
for the Super Bowl
no no I don't think I don't think I'll
be able to I was just thinking about
that cuz y'all are gonna be where are
you gonna be I think we're the
Convention Center fan fest like that
okay yeah but yeah I've never been there
I mean I can help you get in I
appreciate that but this is this is your
hometown I mean it is my hometown I was
just there for Christmas
can we stay at your hands hmm my mother
would actually enjoy that this is a very
sweet woman who likes to make people
happy and cook for them so nice we can
do it we can do a drive-by and just say
hello to her you could do that you could
do that I just stayed with her she was a
lovely time B Texans tomorrow do you
care about your Texans against the
Raiders I do care about them I very much
care about them but it does it does it's
very funny not living in Houston and but
rooting for them there's I keep kind of
almost forgetting that this is happening
in a weird way it's just it's been such
a weird season that never I kept waiting
for something more to happen which is
stupid I mean well you know if you get
in the playoffs anything can happen so I
kind of feel bad but I don't know I'm
not catching the fever
yeah weird yeah you're not well it's
because somebody had to win that
division they want it but it almost
feels like right you know you win this
game and then you got to go to New
England and exactly right and that's not
going to be pretty I also saw the video
you did with a James Corden on The Late
Late Show with dust in the wind
the cancer song yeah that was fun were
you singing or lip-synching I know well
for the video we did do lip-sync but but
it's really our voices they had I didn't
know until I got there they're like and
we're gonna go to the recording to do to
lay down the tracks I went what you're
saying they were very kind and it
doesn't have to be it doesn't have to be
beautiful so that was a weight off my
shoulders
the movie is hidden figures wide
released begins today and it's Jim plays
Paul Stafford the head engineer of
NASA's space task
and this is in the 60s when John Glenn
was being sent into space but had a
group of african-american women who
played a significant role in the helping
of launching and my doing a good job and
you're doing an excellent job
and Kevin Costner is also in the movie
but Jim plays a genius hello yeah yeah
who's trying to keep the woman down so
oh okay so you're the bad guy i yeah i
i'm a bit of a personification of some
less than attractive attributes that
maybe some people had at that time
alright so hidden figures also big bang
theory which is the second most popular
TV show behind their segment yeah i'm on
on football night in America right yeah
that's right you're number one yeah how
many episodes a Big Bang Theory have we
done oh I don't know 250 some I don't I
don't know this is our 10th year so 250
that's a lot no I don't made me hit 250
yet we haven't hit 250 we've hit over
200 we had a party for 200 episodes so
you know but we do 24 every year so you
know I can't ruin that party was and how
many more years are you doing this well
I don't know I mean you know we're there
they have to always you know contract
end and they have to figure out but
you're able to make men ends meet right
I just everything's good right things
are ok I'm gonna be able to see a foot
doctor today it looks like yeah well to
pay that bill god bless it good good
luck with that
hopefully it's not broken and always
great to hear from you Jim oh wait tell
Tommy tell Todd we settle oh I will I
will
Thank You bud all right that's a Jim
Parsons Big Bang Theory and also the
movie hidden figures he plays a bad guy
in that movie the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]